Температура - 90 градусів.
Я сиджу в тісному, напівтемному дерев'яному приміщенні разом із сорока незнайомими людьми.
І ми всі голі.
Коли я вперше прийшла в німецьку сауну, мені спочатку було некомфортно.
Але незабаром я помітила, що ніхто не звертав особливої уваги на оголені тіла один одного.
Єдиною людиною, яка дивилася на інших, була я сама.
Тому що за півгодини перебування у сауні я побачила, напевно, більше оголених тіл,
ніж за все своє життя.
Фігури найрізноманітніших типів і ступеня волосатості.
Це було заворожуюче і ледь не пізнавально.
Мільйони німців регулярно відвідують сауну.
Але невже обов'язково ходити туди голим?
А чому ні?
У цьому нічого поганого, це ж наша культура.
Чому? Навіть не знаю ... Тому що так було завжди. В сауну ніколи не ходили в одязі.
Гігієна?
Можливо, це більш гігієнічно.
Тому що в одязі негігієнічно.
Це дозволяє тілу краще прогрітися.
Так можна краще пропотіти.
Це свого роду спосіб подолати бар'єри.
Коли проводиш в сауні весь день, то вже й не помічаєш, що ти голий.
Авжеж, бути голим - це свобода.
Але свобода не абсолютна.
Є суворі правила, яких слід дотримуватися
в німецькій сауні:
1.Як ви вже, певно, зрозуміли, правило номер один -
жодного одягу.
2.Правило номер два - між вашою шкірою і будь-якою поверхнею сауни
завжди має бути рушник.
3. Правило номер три: жодних розмов.
Тс-с!
Вибачте.
Апогей будь-якого походу в сауну - це так званий Aufguss - піддача пари.
І це щось особливе.
Ось як все відбувається:
Ви приходите в призначений час і знаходите собі місце в сауні.
Пар піддають в два або три заходи, з кожним разом стає дедалі спекотніше.
У паузах можна вийти з лазні, щоб охолонути.
Наприклад, постояти голим в черзі в душ.
Особливо сміливі можуть зануритися в крижану воду.
У кожного етапу піддачі пару є своя тематика або назва.
У воду додають якийсь аромат, наприклад, евкаліпта.
Якщо пощастить, можуть роздати маленькі чашечки з кавовим або соляним скрабом,
а також з медом.
Тоді всі дружно починають намащуватися медом з голови до ніг.
Всім керує "майстер сауни".
Він стежить за порядком, піддає пар і влаштовує необхідні "танці з рушником",
щоб гаряче повітря поширювалось по всьому приміщенню.
Масове потіння голяком - не найбільш звичне заняття.
І комусь воно може здатися дурним.
Але лише поки ви самі не спробуєте.